IT'S A REALITY.
>> AND THAT NEW REALITY IS
CHANGING AND SAVING LIVES.
IN 2015, DR. RODRIGUEZ, WELL, HE
PUSHED THINGS EVEN FURTHER
PERFORMING THE MOST EXTENSIVE
FACE TRANSPLANT EVER ATTEMPTED.
PATRICK WAS A VOLUNTEER FIRE
FIGHTER FROM MISSISSIPPI.
>> VOLUNTEER FIREMAN.
>> GREATEST JOB IN THE WORLD.
>> Sean: YOU DON'T EVEN GET PAID
FOR IT.
>> WELL YOU DO WHAT YOU LOVE.
>> Sean: IN 2001 HE RAN INTO A
BURNING BUILDING TO RESCUE A
WOMAN THAT WAS TRAPPED INSIDE.
SUDDENLY THE BURNING ROOF
COLLAPSED DIRECTLY ONTO
PATRICK'S HEAD.
>> ROOF COLLAPSED ON PATRICK
KNOCKING DOWN HIS HELMET.
HE FELT THE MASK ON HIS FACE WAS
MELTING.
>> Sean: PATRICK HELD HIS
BREATH.
HE JUMPED OUT OF A WINDOW WITH
HIS MELTING FACE MASK CLINGING
TO HIS FACE.
IT EXCLAIMED HIS SCALP, HIS
NOSE, HIS LIPS, HIS EARS HIS
EYELIDS AND ALL THE SKIN ON HIS
FACE.
>> I REMEMBER EVERYTHING FROM
GETTING IN THE AMBULANCE TO THE
HELICOPTER.
DON'T REMEMBER VERY MUCH AFTER
THAT.
>> Sean: HE WAS BURNED SO BADLY
THAT HIS FELLOW FIRE FIGHTERS,
THEY COULDN'T EVEN TELL WHO IT
WAS.
>> I HAD NO IDEA WHO I HAD UNTIL
WE PUT HIM IN THE REST AND HE
PULLED IT DOWN OVER HIS FACE AND
HAD THE PICTURE WITH THE KIDS.
THAT'S WHEN I KNEW WHO I HAD.
I MEAN, IT WAS A ROTTEN DAM DAY.
>> Sean: YOU SAID IN AN
INTERVIEW YOU WOULD DO IT AGAIN
TOMORROW.
>> YEAH.
I HATE THAT I CAN'T DO IT NOW.
>> Sean: THIS BURNING ROOF
LITERALLY COLLAPSES ON YOUR
HEAD.
IT DESTROYED YOUR EYELIDS, YOUR
LIPS, YOUR EARS, YOUR NOSE.
>> I CAN STILL TALK.
I MEAN, I CAN STILL COMMUNICATE.
I COULD -- I NEVER THOUGHT IT
WAS AS BAD AS WHAT IT WAS?
EVEN WHEN MY FRIENDS CAME UP
THEY WOULD BE ALL UPSET AND I
WOULD BE LIKE, CHILL OUT, I GOT
THIS.
I NEVER THOUGHT IT WAS THAT BAD.
>> Sean: WHEN YOU LOOKED IN THE
MIRROR --
>> I DIDN'T ACTUALLY SEE MYSELF
UNTIL PROBABLY NOVEMBER.
I GOT INJURED IN SEPTEMBER.
PROBABLY NOVEMBER OF THAT YEAR,
THEY HAD CUT A LITTLE PIN HOLE
IN ONE OF MY EYELIDS BECAUSE
THEY HAD EVERYTHING COVERED,
SKIN GRAFT.
I LOOKED IN THE MIRROR AND ALL I
COULD DO, I SAID, THIS IS IT?
I CAN'T DO THIS.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU MEAN YOU
CAN'T DO THIS.
>> WELL, IT JUST, I HAD KIDS.
IT WAS JUST A TOUGH TIME.
I NEVER GOT A DAY OFF FROM THE
INJURY.
WHEN YOU WALK OUT IN PUBLIC, IT
WAS DAILY.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST SO --
THERE'S NO WAY TO EXPLAIN
EVERYTHING.
>> Sean: THIS INJURY FOLLOWS YOU
WHEREVER YOU ARE.
>> RIGHT, YOU NEVER GET A DAY
OFF.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
YOU GO TO THE BALL FIELD, YOU
HAVE TO PREPARE YOURSELF FOR THE
KID THAT GOES RUNNING OFF
SCREAMING.
>> Sean: HOW PAINFUL IS THAT?
THAT'S GOT TO BE PAINFUL.
>> YOU NEVER KNOW.
>> Sean: AND YOU'RE LIVING WITH
THIS FOR 14 YEARS.
>> I WENT TO MY EYE DOCTOR AND
HE TOLD ME, HE SAID BASICALLY
WE'VE DONE ALL WE CAN DO.
I CAN'T REBUILD EYELIDS, I CAN'T
MAKE THEM BLINK RIGHT.
AND A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE, THEY
TOLD ME, HE WAS DRIVING ME UP TO
THE DOCTOR THAT DAY AND ON OUR
WAY HOME AND HE SAID I'M GOING
TO LOOK INTO THE POSSIBILITY OF
FACE TRANSPLANT AND HE GOOGLED
FACE TRANSPLANTS BE IN UNITED
STATES AND IT SHOWED UP IN
BALTIMORE THAT HE HAD DONE ONE
EARLIER AND HE E-MAILED HIM AND
THE NEXT DAY THEY CALLED.
I MEAN, IT WAS JUST LIKE, GOD
SENT, LIKE EVERYTHING LINED UP
AS IT SHOULD.
>> OPEN YOUR MOUTH FOR ME.
OKAY.
JUST RELAX LET ME FEEL YOUR LIPS
HERE.
>> Sean: EVEN AFTER 71 SURGERIES
AND SKIN GRAFTS FROM HIS LEGS,
FOR 14 YEARS PATRICK LIVED WITH
WHAT DOCTORS DESCRIBED AS PIN
HOLE VISION.
A MASS OF SCAR TISSUE WAS ALL
THAT WAS LEFT.
HIS EYELIDS, HIS LIPS, EARS,
NOSE, COMPLETELY DESTROYED.
>> WE'VE BEEN EVALUATING PATRICK
IN NEW YORK AT NYU, THE ENTIRE
FACE, EARS, SCALP, GIVE RID OF
ALL THE PORTIONS OF THE FACE
THAT WERE BURNED IN THE FIRE AND
MAKE HIM LOOK NORMAL.
>> Sean: WITH DR. RODRIGUEZ ON
BOARD, PATRICK FINALLY HAD HOPE
BUT THEY STILL NEEDED TO FIND A
DONOR.
>> DONE A LOT FOR HIM WORKING
HARD EVERY DAY TRYING TO GET
THIS TRANSPLANT DONE SO
HOPEFULLY IT'S NOT MUCH LONGER.
>> GET UP IN THE MORNING AND YOU
THINK IT'S DAY TO DAY, YOU KNOW.
JUST NEXT DAY, IT'S THE SAME
WAY, JUST, IT'S HOW IT IS.
SO HOPEFULLY IT WILL HAPPEN
SOON.
IT'S IN GOD'S HANDS.
SO IT WILL HAPPEN WHEN HE'S
READY FOR IT TO HAPPEN.
I KNOW HE HAS AN ANGEL OUT THERE
FOR ME SOMEWHERE AND ONE DAY
HOPEFULLY WHEN THAT DAY COMES,
THAT FAMILY IS DRAWN, BECAUSE I
COULD NOT IMAGINE LOSING
SOMEBODY AT A YOUNG AGE AND THEN
HAVING BE ASKED TO GIVE WHAT
THEY'RE ASKING TO GIVE.
>> Sean: FINALLY THE CALL CAME.
THERE WAS A MATCH.
>> YOU HAVE TO TELL THEM, THIS
MAY NOT WORK.
YOU MAY NOT SURVIVE THIS.
>> MOST PEOPLE KNOW THAT I'M A
VERY CLEAR STRAIGHTFORWARD
SHOOTER AND I TELL THEM, THIS
OPERATION COULD KILL YOU.
I HATE TO USE THIS PHRASE
BECAUSE IT IS A SO SILLY AND
CLICHE BUT YOU WERE WILLING TO
BE THE GUINEA PIG.
YOU WERE WILLING TO RISK YOUR
LIFE.
BUT YOU ALSO KNEW THAT THIS
WOULD ADVANCE MEDICAL SCIENCE.
>> I NEVER HAD ANY DOUBT.
I MEAN, FROM DAY ONE I TOLD DR.
RODRIGUEZ, WHATEVER IT TAKES,
LET'S GET IT DONE.
>> GENTLEMEN HAS FIVE CHILDREN
AND I NEED HIM TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS OPERATION COULD KILL
YOU AND YOU COULD LEAVE YOUR
CHILDREN WITHOUT THEIR FATHER.
>> Sean: WAS THERE ANY
HESITANCY?
>> NO HESITATION.
ON THE MORNING OF THE OPERATION,
WITH OUR ENTIRE TEAM READY TO
GO, I ASKED HIM ONCE AGAIN,
PATRICK, ARE YOU SURE YOU WANT
TO DO THIS?
I WILL CALL OFF THE WHOLE THING
RIGHT NOW.
I DO NOT WANT YOU TO FEEL BAD
ABOUT THIS.
ON ALL INSTANCES, NO HESITATION,
I NEED THIS.
LET'S MOVE FORWARD.
.
>> Sean: WHAT DOES IT FEEL LIKE
FOR YOU?
YOU'RE ALSO IN THIS GAME.
YOU'RE NOT IN MEDICINE TO USE
LIVES, YOU'RE IN MEDICINE TO
SAVE LIVES.
>> AND THAT'S A LOT OF PRESSURE.
>> Sean: A LOT OF PRESSURE.
>> NO QUESTION.
EVERYBODY'S GOT A LOT TO LOSE IN
ALL OF THIS, AND I FEEL
ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE IF
SOMETHING BAD HAPPENS.
WHICH THINGS COULD HAPPEN THAT
ARE OUT OF CONTROL.
BUT THERE IS THAT POTENTIAL
GLORY IF WE CAN ACHIEVE THIS, I
THINK ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE COULD
POTENTIALLY HELP.
>> YOU READY TO GO?
HOW YOU FEELING?
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE CARE OF YOU,
OKAY?
>> Sean: AFTER 14 YEARS OF
WAITING, THAT MOMENT HAS NOW
ARRIVED.
DR. RODRIGUEZ AND HIS MASSIVE
MEDICAL TEAM, THEY WERE ABOUT TO
ATTEMPT THE MOST COMPLEX FACE
TRANSPLANT EVER PERFORMED IN